sur la banquise de la baie du son au
large des nougloac ce n'est pas une
bonne journée pour la chasse aux phoques
seulement une toute petite surface d'eau
libre qui permet de percevoir quelques
bêtes
mais les tirs ratent la cible on engage
des chasseurs locaux puis on prend des
jeunes qui ont pas la chance souvent de
sortir puis d'aller découvrir la chasse
ensemble on paye la journée on sort sur
une journée complète à aller chercher
des phoques aller chercher du caribou à
aller chercher de la perdrix aller à la
chasse à l'outarde en collaboration avec
l'école secondaire du village
l'organisme sérivait qui finance des
sorties comme celle-ci pour aider à la
transmission des traditions de chasse et
de survie on mange beaucoup encore la
nourriture qu'on cherche mais on mange
beaucoup aussi les gens les déchets
Charlie mokawak a œuvré toute sa vie à
la préservation de la culture et des
traditions de son peuple il agit
aujourd'hui comme guide c'est important
qu'on garde notre identité notre culture
notre langue pourrait être fier pour
être capable de passer les défis qu'on a
dans la vie économiquement ou bien
socialement
lui enseigne les traditions de la chasse
et de survie dans la toundra et
accompagne les élèves avec le directeur
de série V les jeunes sont stimulés les
jeunes hommes sont fiers de sortir sont
fiers de montrer leur skills que les
jeunes filles commencent aussi à vouloir
moi aussi je vais aller chasser
l'organisme a bu non lucratif cerivique
c'est aussi une série hydroponique et
des ateliers de cuisine pour les jeunes
que les choses se passent compliquer que
ça à faire les cuisines de base puis je
peux subvenir à tes besoins beaucoup
une génération qui navigue entre
tradition et modernité
après une chasse au phoque infructueuse
notre groupe s'est déplacé sur une île
après avoir repéré le passage de caribou
comme cela
pourquoi c'est important d'apprendre
tout ça
une partie de cette venaison sera
utilisée par Anne c'est son équipe pour
cuisiner et distribuer gratuitement un
repas hebdomadaire puis chacun des
chasseurs prendra sa part
le reste pourrait être servi lors de
repas communautaire ou encore déposer
dans ce qu'on appelle le congélateur
communautaire
je trouve important qu'on partage le
sagesse du passé parce que nos ancêtres
ont survécu dans des périodes ou des
situations extrêmes moi je mange
beaucoup des aliments que je cherche
moi-même je partage avec la famille puis
une belle vie
dans 10 ans 15 ans est-ce qu'il va avoir
assez de gens qui vont encore chasser
pour subvenir aux besoins de leur
famille et de la population vous êtes
convaincus de ça je suis convaincu parce
que dans le passé il y avait des génies
qui posaient le même question il y a
déjà 40 ans puis ça continue